and for us we had a lot of difficulties
uh
if it's money money raising
i i've just
said last week in the interview that i
had that there was one investor that
they actually had to invest a lot a big
amount of money for us
and by the end we we saw that this was a
scheme or a scam
and
yeah and we almost had no money and
actually we the founders
[Applause]
put money in the company in order to pay
salaries
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i am with akiva
agamon the ceo and founder of wise site
technologies ltd
akiva was born in jerusalem and is
married with four children currently
living in nestarim as close as possible
to nature he holds a master's degree in
physics and electro optics and worked in
a classified position in the defense
industries and was the key engineer of
the aero 3 missile and of many and
various classified projects
since 2016 he is the founder of ysite a
smooth and straightforward smart parking
technology for a better parking
experience
akivamon welcome to 20 minute leaders
all the way right now from the hebrew
university campus but really from the
wise side offices soon to be in a new
location how are you today
i'm great thank you thank you for
inviting me
so jerusalem jerusalem and smart parking
and startups in israel and all my
favorite things
we're going to be talking about today
it's really really awesome akiva you
have such a unique you know experience
both in the iai as the
head of product management but
previously a senior systems engineer so
both engineering and product management
bachelors of bar elon masters at the
hebrew university staff sergeant from
the idf and today founder and ceo of a
very very cool startup that honestly all
of us want and need a long time ago so
akiva welcome to the show and share with
me a little bit about you and and who
you are
okay thank you michael so my name is
akiva almond i'm the founder and ceo of
why site
i'm living in a small village next to
your jerusalem called the nessarim
and i married with four amazing kids
so
that is about me
and i know what it worked at the iai for
six years and so
and
and together with my partner from the
iai we believe that we could do
something different to bring something
new to the world that actually affects
all of us so we thought about why site
incredible and the the you will partner
with your friends and why say where
where did this really come about you
know
i understand that all of us you know
have are having issues with smart
mobility and smart cities and parking
but the gap from having this pain point
to actually forming a company around
that there was a it's pretty long
journey so what was going on throughout
this journey
yeah so actually
together we worked together with my
friend ram rocker which is our cto
and we thought about how we can bring
new technology to the civilian industry
after working with the
uh defense industries the different
defense industries in israel we thought
how we can use the knowledge that we
gathered among those ears
and bring a
new solution
to the civilian field as well so
i'm tired to see
a
traffic jams looking for empty parking
space wasting my time
with traffic
so
we thought about maybe we can have we
could help in that way uh so
with that solution that we have we're
actually helping uh
uh saving time
and saving uh parking fines from the
driver so i think this is a good cause
and it was a good cause to leave the iai
for that
can you take me a little bit higher
level and share with me you know how do
we get to this problem in the first
place so where are we at right now
both in terms of you know the the the
problem in terms of numbers
and scale but also how did we get to
where we are
yeah i think
that
it's not just in israel it's like it's
like a general problem that everybody
wants to have to own their own car to
own their own vehicles so at the end it
comes out that there is infrastructure
and there are roads and infrastructure
plants many years ago
but now we're dealing with the
population
and the population is of course
increasing by the time and the
infrastructure stayed the same
among those all years so the v there are
more vehicles and more traffic and
actually the infrastructure
infrastructure
are is not changing so much so at the
end there are more vehicles more traffic
less parking for those vehicles
so this problem is actually getting uh
difficult and difficult by the year
but you know technology has been around
for
you know much more many more than you
know 10 15 years but let's use 10 15
years as an example because this is when
people were talking about electric
vehicles and we're seeing you know the
world wide web explode and and it's
obvious that you know things around us
are becoming digital yet infrastructure
and cities didn't seem to adapt or even
discuss this issue
even until now how do you explain this
gap between the innovation in the world
and what's actually happening in our
physical spaces
yeah listen it's tough to bring a
revolution and to bring a technology
revolution into the field of
industry parking municipalities
sometimes they are working with the old
methods and just
don't change my game don't don't don't
change anything for me
but i think nowadays without technology
emoticified is adopting our technologies
because they can see they can see
how much it it is easier how much we can
save them a lot of
fraction
uh between the drivers and the parking
officers and actually we're bringing in
the holistic solution uh frictionless
for the municipality so
i think nowadays that trying to adopt
that at first of course at the beginning
we had to get those early adapters so
the technology more
accepting municipalities
but i think nowadays the big
municipalities that are the tougher
municipalities with that aspect they are
approaching us because they can see that
we that we've done something different
with other ones and they try to do that
tell me a little bit about your
experience validating this idea um with
municipalities and figuring out
how can we actually use technology to
help start solving this problem what was
that like for you
actually i think it's it what it was
amazing because
actually we started in a municipality
here in israel
it's for saboni municipality and
with the right person
his name was the italian sacha he was
the ceo of the municipality and together
with him we actually thought about the
solution
we thought about all the information
that we can get
by implementing a small pilot and after
we've done a small step
just to working with small step i think
that is the that is the key factor
but uh
we've done a small pilot together with
the municipality we try to figure out
what their what their their needs the
municipality needs and what is the
information that we can bring them and
after gathering the needs and the
information the big data that we can
generate for them and then
delivering
the
the big data and and the recommendation
and what of what we can do in the
municipality i think that this is
actually um
the the right steps in order to get into
the municipalities and to make a real
difference
very very cool
tell me a little bit about the solution
the technology the solution you know how
you also came up with this technology
also based on your previous experiences
all right so so i will tell i will tell
about that technology i i will just
start about the vision our vision is
that we can work
frictionless with the parking
industry
all over the world
and
with using our solution we can do
automatic automatic payment and
automatic navigation to empty parking
space i'm talking about on-street
offspring and so on
and by doing that we can save
the drivers from getting any parking
tickets so
we can do automatic charge for those
parking spaces
direct drivers to those empty parking
space
spaces actually reducing the traffic
from the
following party helping drivers to get
to empty parking space and
helping him or the driver and handpit
the driver from uh getting any parking
fights
with automatic payment so our vision is
no parking yes sorry no target no
uh no parking fines
and direct drivers and saving time to
the drivers so we developed an iot
device implemented on the street light
poles of the municipality and this
device could recognize
every parking space to know
if the driver that parked in the in this
specific parking space
uh
paid or didn't pay for his for his uh
for his parking space and by the end of
the month at the end we'll send him the
bill no one has to deal with a
a
payment uh just using coins or operating
your app
or getting any parking tickets so
everybo everything is very strict and
direct and
saving a lot of
frustration from the drivers
so nowadays we can do that
and
meantime
it's not working like we're sending the
bills by the end of the month of course
we can do that but nowadays we are
working together with the pay by phone
companies here in israel it's pango in
cello park
so if we can see the driver parked the
car
didn't pay for his parking space we're
sending him sms alert hey listen if you
want to
avoid any parking fines so please
restrict your payment that way we're
saving
100 000 of a parking tickets every year
for the drivers so
and let's win win to the municipality as
well because more income from payment
less income from a from parking fine but
totally
the revenues is higher
how is the solution actually implemented
you know physically in in the streets
how how do you get this information or
how how does all this operation work
that enables you you know in real time
to know what's happening you know in
terms of this part these parking spaces
yeah so
we developed an iot device it's a based
on cameras but the all the cameras all
the analytics that we're doing is
real time on the spot so there is no
images coming out of the system so it's
only information that coming up out of
the system so
those systems implemented on the street
light bulbs of the municipality so
they're covering all the
parking spaces under the coverage of the
system
um
and that way it's actually managing
those
uh parking spaces
so
you're observing the you're basically
observing the entire street and then
you're able through license plate to
identify okay who is this person that is
parking and if the vehicle did not move
for a certain amount of time then you
basically can classify them as having
parked correct yeah and when we cross
the information together with the paid
by phone companies so we can figure out
if his paying is not paying and actually
we help their customers they pan go and
sell up our customers to avoid parking
fines so we're sending those semester
loads and that way increasing revenues
for the messy party helping drivers to
pay for the parking space
and that's why it's a win-win situation
for everyone
so how do these two strategies play play
with each other both you know first in
terms of the partnership with the
municipalities as sort of a go-to-market
strategy i assume also to be able to
gain you know the wise
site into the into the street
but then you're mentioning that you know
a greater vision here is to actually
enable people to navigate to free
parking spaces also on the street that
they might not be aware are available
how do those two strategies come
together here
actually it's very easy because after
implementation of the device we're
bringing together with the municipality
we're bringing the information about the
empty parking spaces for free for the
for the drivers
so
uh
so actually our aim is to implement that
information on waze or google maps so
when you're driving you're already using
your
waze or or
[Music]
a google maps and you can figure out
where there is available parking spots
so we're delivering that information for
free for the driver for the drivers
because the
municipality uh municipalities pays us
in order to implement those devices
uh gather the information and deliver
and help the citizens uh avoid parking
fights and direct them to empty parking
spaces so actually it comes together
it's a win-win situation so now as
you're as you're you know reaching out
to municipalities in terms of the go to
market
what what is their response like is this
a trivial thing for them both in terms
of the
the understanding the pain point
and also the implementation because it
doesn't sound that trivial to put a
camera that overlooks a street
yeah so i think
i think it's
very easy nowadays
if you're getting all the
if if you
dealing with all the privacy issues of
implementing cameras so now of course
we're working together with the privacy
department of israel so we approved that
by that and we're doing other we're
working together with all the regulation
uh here in israel and abroad so
after that it it's very easy to
implement those devices but
of course we're taking care of the
privacy issue
but after the approvement of the
municipality
we're working with the subcontractors so
they are implementing those devices it's
very easy
uh for us and i think nowadays it's only
the beginning because when we can do a
lot more things allow the municipality
for traffic gyms a lot of
the municipality where we can see an
accident occurring in the municipality
to
to call 911
or to to bring the staff
to direct them to the right place in
order to solve the issue so we can do
that um
as a hurry as we can and that way we can
help saving people lives
so beautiful what has been the most
exhilarating and challenging part of
this journey so far
uh i think
it's a
a whole journey there's ups and downs
it's not so easy sometimes we're reading
on the papers about the many companies
that don't exit so it seems to be very
easy to be in israel and to
to do startup company and
and
do an exit so it's not so easy 98 or 99
of the companies fail
so i think the best
thing is
to
work with
with the people with good people uh i
think when you have uh always the same
interest together with your partners so
that comes out well and for us we had a
lot of difficulties uh
if it's money money raising uh
i
just
said last week in an interview that i
had that there was one investor that
they actually had to invest a lot a big
amount of money for us
and by the end we we saw that
this was a scheme or a scam
and
yeah and we almost had no money and
actually we the founders
uh
put money in the company in order to pay
salaries but after a month wow we got
all the all the money from other
investors so
uh it all comes out fine at the end and
the founder journey
take me back to that exact moment you
know you're this the investor that you
know commits to an amount that he can't
that he can't afford perhaps or doesn't
want to afford and
you're now you're in a struggle
situation was there a conversation about
shutting down the company or sort of
giving up what was going on no no no no
no i think that there wasn't
in any in any case there isn't such a
situation that we're going to close the
company because we believe in the
company we believe that we have
something strong something that actually
good
do do do good things
so
i think
it's not only us the founders i think
all the employees in the company are
very
very in the company it's like a family
company or everybody wants the company
to succeed so we're bringing all the
effort in
there is there wasn't any question about
the if we're going to close the company
yes or no
no not at all we believe in the company
akiva thank you very very much for your
time for your energy
i can't wait to be able to navigate to a
free parking space on the street and uh
and i think that what you're doing here
is is so important for you know smart
mobility and you know as technology is
advancing we're just waiting and we're
thirsty for these types of solutions so
i wish you best of luck i hope to see
your cameras all around the world and at
scale and i can only imagine all the
frustration that you're going to save so
many people particularly in tel aviv so
thank you very much and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you so much michael it was a
pleasure
thank you thank you